TC thank you for taking a tick-tock
break to do this interview with us how
are you Lauren good to see it I'm good
my friend how are you how's the
quarantine crew in the quarantine house
we are hanging in there we just got done
with the workouts and now I'm here with
my girl and we're here with you now is
even better I don't think there could be
a more perfect moment to get you during
all this then right after a workout that
feels so OnPoint for how your life is so
we're here to talk about your new kwibi
Shoaib architecture I mean Tyler it's
like hot dude doing construction and
making houses for adorable dogs
is there a [ __ ] brand show for you know
I'm a big background you know
construction so when this opportunity
came I Wesley I want to be a part of
this any way I can and it just worked
out and I'm so excited to share with you
guys it's so much fun and it's so fun to
show and all of our lovers out there
what are you looking for in terms of
like I said I think it has to go with my
home yes Lucas hands like a mini version
of my house so how long does it take to
make each of these houses and how much
would they cost in the real world
because they're pretty spectacular I
would say the build is about five days
and with all the material supply I don't
know if I have an exact price point for
it but you know pretty pricey but I mean
they're worth they're beautiful right
yes and you're making them for some
celebrities some brothel liberties who
were you most nervous to make a house
for deathly Teyana Taylor because I'd
like I'm a huge fan of her music so I
was I was like oh my I'm really meeting
stuff with that like I listen to you and
like jam out to like kind of videos of
me singing your song top my long so I
was like super excited to be here and
she was so cool
you make some houses for a couple of my
feet
ladies the housewives Richards Kyle
Richards is on there I think these are
people any of the thumb flirt with you
or like try to set you up with anybody
I happened but they were just so struck
by the doghouses that you know they kind
of just lost you know they must have
forgot about setting me up with somebody
but now they were so much fun
kyle was great it was so cool good at
least the ban pops house because we were
not building for just like one or two
dogs we were building for a whole bunch
of rescue dogs which is which was like
very partial to me because parley is a
rescue dog as well so mad a lot Harley's
such a good pup right now she's made for
the camera last night oh so Harley's the
woman in your bed right now she is she
does no one else is she defensive like
what do you think Harley would
potentially not like a girlfriend of
yours and would that be just like
anybody she's side eyes and growls and
but it takes time with time she learns
to like love you know what uh kind of
thing myself but she is uh she's like so
Sinai you she has a lot of attitude did
Harley like Hannah brown she did good
time so what's more nerve-racking
revealing one of these dog houses to a
famous person that's made for their baby
or waiting for your name to be called at
a rose ceremony on the Bachelorette
[Music]
I would say there's a few Rose
ceremonies that were definitely a little
little on edge for but also I don't know
I would say definitely pop in the
doghouse is because the roles are
reversed now you know it's like I'm the
I'm the host you know and I got to make
sure that these people are happy this is
go in their backyard my biggest
nightmare was like two months from now
they were just gonna like pile it up and
throw it away but so like we really took
a lot of time to make sure these things
were amazing and like beautiful and
these were I mean these were bigger than
my first names to the apartment so I
gotta ask you Tyler Cameron because I
know Harley's the ones snuggling with
you but are you single right now yes yes
would you be the bachelor again timing
right now is good for it you know I
think my there's a lot of things that
has happened to my life lately and I
think there's a lot of things I want to
get going in my life as well some
businesses like I want to start I want
you my construction company running and
all that that's important to me this
whole world you know of you know having
followers and all this stuff is great
not but I want something that's long
lasting and and I can have forever and
that's why I hope to see in a
construction company so my goal is to
get back going and you know hopefully
something I can have my kids one day and
they can so so does that mean you're
ready for something like would you want
to date somebody by the way you can put
Harley down if you want to talk about
construction here Lauren we're talking
about the rebuilding of your life and
how you know you got to build a good
foundation for things do you see I'm
doing there yeah I get it I get it but
you know the foundation I think the fact
my first foundation I need to work on is
myself making sure one is straight
around me and getting my career and my
life in balance and then hopefully
someone else can help me balance myself
a little bit
I have to ask you the question why did
Hannah quarantine with you did you guys
have unfinished business what was the
thing that came out of you guys spending
that time together we just you know we
kind of reconnected over some things we
were both going through and we were
there for each other and we decided you
know like it was never supposed to be
that long or a quarantine at all just
supposed to be a good weekend where
things kind of went you know got a
little crazy with the whole qur'an with
like the quarantine and everything like
that so it was a lot longer but trip and
expected but it was good we got to air a
lot of things out and like you know
become you know friends again and put a
lot of stuff in our past you just think
you feel like very like when when you're
there you're there you're locked in like
and I notice it I don't like it it's
hard to keep my eyes off you
so that's not well you're gonna keep
that between you and Hannah well why did
she ultimately leave okay she had to get
back to a family yeah TV shows or movies
that have made you cry the judge this is
us best man holiday and are you by the
way are you still quarantine 'you've
been posting a little bit less of the
videos do you still have the rest of the
full crew there is Matt there and you're
all here we're all here hold not strong
and Matt's actually in the in the garage
that we just built he's working out in
there brown bears here on the couch
Ryan's robbers actually dancing right
now shirt off another image you don't
want to see necessarily you know we've
seen it we've actually I think we've
seen maybe every guy in that a lot Matt
James said to go on The Bachelorette
would you still tell him to go on the
show now especially after the the social
media moment he and Claire seem to have
yeah I think I think if they can you sit
there talk as mature adults they can you
know have some things out I think Matt
is an incredible person and quite a
catch
I'm a player but she seems very pretty
and she seems like a fun outgoing person
very adventurous and what I've seen on
social media so I think they both share
a lot of things in common when it comes
with that but uh I would love to see
them hash it out and maybe build a
relationship from there who knows how
they are both intelligent let me know
they just need to talk it out as adults
and it's just crazy there's all this
buzz going on before you even get to
meet each other which kind of stings
well I don't know I think it could make
for a really unique season of the show
something new I mean Matt defended you I
remember he was like when Hannah asked
you for that drink he was like my boys
not a second choice so I'm wondering did
you feel a little defensive when Clare
seemed to come format on Twitter I
actually laughed my ass off I thought it
was great you know I was definitely you
know of course I want to defend that but
I think they both you know I understand
where Clarence coming from you know and
I understand what Matt's coming from so
that's why I think they both need to sit
there and talk it out and I hope they
can get past it and have fun together I
think like Matt could put a smile on
anyone's face and and in a time as
stressful as being the Reid I think
having someone that can put a smile on
your face means a lot and so that's why
I think it'd be important for them to
you know to hash things out and be with
each other and have some have some time
together so he's still going on the show
I guess so you guys are still
quarantined together you're gonna build
a house for Harley um I also got to ask
you you know does being a daddy to
Harley make you think about like having
kids one day all that is that are you
gonna hold basketball team I wanna like
I neither starting five in a six-man I
mean I don't know I also comes to
whatever my wife wants but I would love
that kids you know I want to continue
you know I think that's you know more
life is the most most beautiful thing in
the world you know so y'all are wrong in
the comments well I know that you are
not the father not the father of gigi
hadid 'he's baby which you are you are
incredible at transitions long
thank you I loved the way that you have
a little look
practice makes perfect no I'm sure by
the end of the show you were building
the best dog houses even better than the
beginning exactly
so did you know I don't know if you and
Gigi ever talked about her wanting to be
a mom did you know she wanted to do this
do you think she's gonna be a great mom
and have you reached out to her yes
she's going to the most incredible mom
she is one of the sweetest most caring
people I've ever met so I'm super
excited for her did you shoot her a text
or anything she's pretty good yeah is
this your mom's house that you guys are
in this is yeah that's special I always
wanted to my goal is to surprise her and
remodel this house for her but so I
still it's my little brothers to be
model it for them now and make sure they
have a place they can always call home
so that's you know that's my goal right
now I love has it been cool to be there
during all this and Spence yeah you know
it's the silver lining within all of
this is that although you know it was
tried to what happened to my mother
I couldn't imagine being you know back
in New York my brother be back in FAU my
brother brother be FSU back in school
because it because I mean I've seen the
challenges and the tough times that
they've faced since it you know cuz I
got to be here
and so like the silver lining is I'm
grateful that I've been able to be here
and be there for them or whatnot because
I couldn't imagine not
I couldn't imagine them being alone
right now and myself being alone either
yeah it's a your your last year of your
life what you've been through it's been
what like I can't even imagine how much
you've probably changed and grown I
wonder what Tyler looks like a couple
years ago because we've talked about
this I've been through what you're going
through and I am a believer that like
God sends angels your way at certain
points when you need them and I do
wonder and I really mean this like
sincerely do you kind of look at that
time that you and Hannah had is like you
guys getting through something together
how much did that help you having her
around like move forward and in a time
when your world was turned upside down
yeah knows definite has to have her here
you know she was someone to talk to
about things and Iran
you know for everyone she's great and
she's she's someone that can listen and
give her perspective and you know and
she's very pleasant in that setting
okay I'm gonna sneak one more in Hannah
recently said she wants to have a
relationship so do you wish her well on
that is it possible she's an amazing
person and I you know she I wish her
happiness and and whatever it is you
know whatever form that is yeah of
course
so you're doing this show would you do
another season is there any dream
celebrity you want to build a house for
yeah I need I need to go build LeBrons
dogs a house you did build Snoop Dogg
stars a house I need to build there's
some really cool people honey to build a
house for so yeah I would love for a
season two that'd be amazing
is there any Bravo Liberty you didn't
get to meet that you wanted to I thought
I thought you would I thought you'd
build Andy Cohen a doghouse
well I forget he's like the host I got I
mean I was thinking about this shows of
course Andy good I love Andy toe he
loves you that's my guy I would build
him whatever he needed doghouse kitchen
bathroom you name it I'll do it
that's my guy so but he's in New York so
that's the problem we do our things in
LA so hopefully you know next season we
can maybe travel a little bit maybe you
go hit like Doug the pug in Nashville
and Andy in New York Martha Stewart's in
New York I didn't want to ask and I'm
getting serious again from in here but
it is Mother's Day this weekend I hope
you know like I'm sending you my love
are you guys gonna do anything to honor
your mom this weekend or what are your
plans I appreciate it I think my
brother's gonna have that conversation
on what we want to do you know it's kind
of something that you know this is gonna
be a you know Easter was tough so I can
only imagine what this is gonna be but
uh you know we are gonna make the most
of the day we're gonna honor here we're
gonna stop right here that's the most
important thing let's celebrate her end
and grateful for all the you know
usually had with her so
we are thinking of you and I'm sorry
that you're going through this I really
I think you're gonna years from now look
back at this and be like wow I grew 10
years in a year because the procedure
[Music]